Audubillahi mina Shaytan regime Bismillahu Rahmanur Rahim Allahumma saliya ala Sayyidina Muhammadin Wa ala Ali Sayyidina Muhammadin kamasalayta wa salamta wa barakta wa rahimta wa tarahamta ala Ibrahim Wa ala Ali Ibrahim fil alamina Inna Kahmidu Majid Rabbish Rahli Sadri wa yaserli Amri Wahlul Uqtata millisani of Kahukawli Assalamu alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatu
Now that we understand these meanings of Rab and Rahman and Raheem, now that we understand these terms, I want to share with you a beautiful spiritual representation that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has created for us through the example of the womb, the Rahem.
To quickly reiterate these terms, Rab is a combination of six things in classical Arabic.
The definition is a Rabbuhu al-Maliku was Sayyidu al-Murabbi al-Murshid wal-Muna'im al-Qayyim So a Rab is an owner and he is the one with complete authority over its property He is the one who nurtures his creation guides it benefits it by bestowing generous and undeserving gifts upon it and he is the one who maintains it
So this is who Allah is, right?
That's His primary role with His creation of Rabb.
And all His other attributes, they basically center around and they stem from His Rabul biyya.
So if someone asks, who is Allah?
The answer to that question is Allah is Rabb.
Now, as for His nature,
His nature is Ar-Rahman and Ar-Raheem.
So the manner in which he executes or the way he carries out the functions of his Rubul biyya, it is through intense and consistent love, compassion and mercy.
So now that we understand these concepts, I want to share this example that Allah has created for us through the womb.
You know, by studying the womb, we can actually understand a lot about our master's plan for us.
Just by studying the relationship of the womb with its fetus.
Because this womb, it is the first rub of the fetus.
And it demonstrates the exact same principles of Rahmaniyya and Rahimiyya in its interaction with it.
This is why there is a Hadith in which Rasulullah , he said This world is a womb for the afterlife.
In other words, the story of our lives in this world, it tells a tale about the kind of life that we're going to have in the afterlife because
This world, this dunya that we're living in is the womb or access the womb and we are the fetus in that womb.
And just as the brief and temporary residence in a womb is actually preparation for this worldly life,
Our stay in this temporal world is nothing more than a short duration of preparation for the afterlife.
Now, if you look at the Rahem, the womb, you'll see all six principles of Rubbiya at work.
It has ownership and it has authority over the embryo, right?
It nurtures the embryo, it helps the embryo grow and develop into a fetus.
So the womb is Malik, it is Sayyid and it is Murabbi.
Then we see that the womb, it bestows these priceless gifts upon the fetus to the development of its eyes, its nose, its ears, hands, feet, the heart, the intellect and all of its internal and external organs.
So we can see that the womb is also the Muna'im, the bestower of gifts.
We also know that the womb, it manages the entire development process of the embryo from its conception all the way until it is fully developed.
So the womb is also ayam.
So we can see that the womb, it actually acts as the very first physical rub that we come in contact with.
And this very first act, it actually demonstrates the design
of how Allah created this mechanism.
It demonstrates the act of Rububiyya by carrying out all six functions of the definition of the word Rab, right?
Malik, Sayyid, Murabbi, Murshid, Munhayim, Qayyim.
Now, what happens once the baby is delivered into this world?
Who is the baby handed over to?
It is handed over to its loving mother who becomes the next immediate Rabb of that baby.
Not the father, the mother.
It's the mother that becomes the next Rabb.
Why?
Because she feeds it.
She takes care of it.
There is this transference of Rubbiya that takes place.
The mother now takes ownership of the baby.
The mother now takes authority over it.
The mother assumes the responsibility of nurturing it, helping it grow and develop, teaching it, guiding it, setting it to purpose, showering all these gifts and blessings upon it.
She becomes the one who maintains that baby's sustenance in all its various forms, physical, emotional, psychological.
So we can see that our mothers become the next immediate Arab
Right after the Rububiya of the womb, the Raham, it's completed.
Now father is also a Rab, but his Rububiya gets executed through the mother.
You see, the father always uses the mother as a means for her.
He facilitates her functions of Rububiya.
That's the role of the father, but the primary caretaker of the child is always the mother.
So now let's study this Hadith to better understand the underlying principles that are at work.
So Rasulullah , he said, .
This temporal world is the womb of the afterlife.
So let's examine the fetus and the womb of its mother.
Is it the womb actually doing all the work?
Or is it the mother doing all the work behind the scenes and letting this womb act as an intermediary between herself and her child?
Is it the womb or the mother?
We know it's always the mother, right?
The mother is the one taking care of the baby's needs.
She is the one eating all the right things.
She is making sure she doesn't bump into things so that her baby doesn't get hurt.
She's the one getting all the ultrasounds done, taking all those painful but necessary blood tests, all those injections.
So she is the one actually suffering for the baby.
Baby is living comfortably in the womb, but it's the mother doing all the work, right?
The mother is the one doing all the hard work all along.
But from the perspective of the fetus, who is doing all the work?
The womb, not the mother.
You see, the fetus has absolutely no knowledge of its mother.
All it knows, all it recognizes, all it understands is the womb.
If I ask the fetus, who do you think is feeding you?
Who do you think is nurturing you, taking care of you, sustaining you?
Who is doing all the work that is necessary for your health and development?
What will the fetus reply?
The womb.
The fetus has absolutely no knowledge of the existence of its mother.
You see?
What mother?
Where's the mother?
I don't see a mother.
All I see is the womb.
There is no mother.
It's just cause and effect.
When I tell this fetus, no, no, it's not the womb, it's the mother.
She is the one feeding you.
She's the one taking care of you.
This womb is only an intermediary.
It's a means.
And the fetus says, you know, what are you talking about?
It's the umbilical cord that's feeding me.
That's what gets me this blood that is carrying all the nutrients.
I get fed by that, the umbilical cord.
The umbilical cord is responsible for my development.
There is no mother.
And so I explain, no, no, there is a mother.
She is all around you.
You are within the love, the care, the concern, and the mercy of your mother.
This womb wouldn't exist if she didn't exist.
And this womb that you're in, it's actually temporary.
This is not the world you were created for.
Believe me, this world is filthy, it is dark, it is immensely constricted.
There is an amazing and a beautiful world that exists outside this womb that has been created just for you.
And that world is so magnificent that you cannot even imagine its glory right now within this womb.
Trust me, this womb is filth compared to that world.
So if you think this womb is kind and merciful to you, let me tell you, it doesn't even compare to the love and the mercy of your mother.
Because your mother is going to take care of you in the next world.
She will shower you with so much love that you have absolutely no idea.
You cannot even imagine that while you're in this womb.
But the fetus says, what are you talking about?
I am really really happy here.
Everything I need is being taken care of for me right here.
Why do I need to have another world?
I don't know why you keep talking to me about this mother and another world and an afterlife.
There is no mother.
There is no world outside this womb.
You're crazy.
Okay show me.
Show me this world that you keep talking about.
Show it to me right now.
I want to see it.
Prove to me that there is another world.
Prove to me that there is actually a mother.
I'm not gonna believe you unless and until I see that world and until I see that mother.
And I say, I can't show it to you right now, but I promise when you transition out of this world, this womb, you'll see both of them.
Oh, so now I'm supposed to trust you.
I'm supposed to trust your belief system, your intellect?
What if you're wrong?
Now this is us with Allah in this world.
There are so many of us denying the existence of the mother living in the comforts of this womb, of this dunya.
So now,
I begin this logical path of explanation and I say, look, you have been given these eyes, but there is so little to see here.
You've been given these ears, but there's so little to hear.
You've been given taste buds, but there is so little to taste here.
You have a nose with this magnificent ability to smell, but there's not a single fragrance here.
You have arms, you have feet, you have all these amazing gifts, but you cannot benefit from them within this womb.
So think about it.
These are of no use to you inside this womb, which means there must be another world that is out there, a world where you will be able to use and benefit from these gifts.
Think about it.
Your only purpose in this womb, in this world, is to draw your sustenance from your mother and develop these organs.
In other words, you're here so that you can prepare them for the next world where you will actually be using them, where you will actually benefit from them.
But does the fetus understand that?
No.
It doesn't.
To the fetus, the concept of another world and the existence of a mother is just ridiculous.
Just as the concept of a God and an afterlife is absurd to so many of us.
So now what happens?
This fetus continues to live in its ignorance and its arrogance until the nine months complete.
Now what happens?
Contractions begin.
The fetus starts panicking.
What's going on here?
What's happening?
This is what was promised to you.
I told you this day would come.
I told you this world is temporary.
So now with those contractions, this beautiful world of the fetus, this magnificent world it was living happily and comfortably in, it starts crumbling around it.
It starts falling apart all around it.
Now, isn't that exactly the description of the Day of Judgment?
When the earth is shaken up with its earthquakes.
And the earth discharges its burden.
And man says, What is wrong with this world?
What is wrong with this earth?
Yaw ma izin tuhaddisu akhbaraha bi anna rabbaka o haalaha
On this day, it will report the news of which your master has commanded it.
Yauma izin, yasduru naasu ashtatan liyurao a'malahum.
On this day, people will separate out, and they will be shown the results of their deeds.
Fa man yaamal misqala zarratin khairan yara.
So, whoever did an atom's weight of good will see it.
Wa man yaamal misqala zarratin sharran yara.
and whoever did an Adam's weight of evil will see it so the world of the fetus now comes to an end and it is forced out of it it is pushed out of it against its will you see does the fetus have a choice in whether it wants to stay in the womb or not no whether it wants to or not whether it's ready or not once its time is up that's it
It is pushed out into the next world.
It dies in the womb in order to be born again in the next world, you see.
Its death in the womb results in its creation in this world.
That's what the word intaqal means.
It comes from naqala, which means a transference.
It also means a copy or a replica.
That's what naqala means, a copy or a replica.
Why?
Because the next world is going to be a copy, it is going to be a replica of the first.
If you did good in the world, in this world, you will find good in the next world.
If you did evil in this world, you will find evil in the next world.
It's going to be a replica, it's going to be a copy.
If the fetus has not properly developed its eyes, its ears, its brain, its limbs in the womb of its mother, it is going to suffer the consequences of that in the afterlife of this dunya.
SubhanAllah.
So now this temporal world of the fetus is destroyed and it comes into this huge world that he was informed about.
this world that was promised to him in the womb.
He is now forced into this world, this afterlife that he chose not to believe in.
And then, as soon as it's out of the womb, who is the baby handed to?
The mother.
Subhanallah.
The mother that he said did not exist, the mother he denied his entire life in the womb.
So you can see that the fetus goes through the exact same confusion of the seen and the unseen while it's in the womb of its mother.
That's so many of us go through in this life.
The fetus that accepts the rububiya of its mother through the womb comes out fully developed and is now capable of enjoying all the benefits
that the afterlife has to offer, which is this physical world for the fetus.
But the fetus that rejected the rububia of the womb, it comes out underdeveloped, blind, deaf, mute, physically challenged, mentally challenged, incapable of benefiting from the joys and pleasures that this world has to offer.
We are all going through this exact same process in life.
Why?
Because Ad-Dunya Rahmul Akhra this world is the womb for the afterlife.
And here we have our Rab telling us, look, follow the Sharia, keep yourself clean, keep yourself pure, do your Salat, complete your fast, pay your Zakat, fulfill your obligations of Hajj.
And what do we say?
Why?
How is this going to help me?
It's not going to help you here.
That's not the purpose.
The obligations of Sharia is not meant for this world.
It's the sustenance for the development of our spiritual limbs.
That's what Sharia is.
It's a means like the womb.
It's a tool.
It's a mechanism, a means, an intermediary for the development of our spiritual limbs, for the development of our spiritual organs that are going to help us live a good life
After this world is over, that is where we will benefit from these fully developed spiritual organs.
In the afterlife, all we're doing here in this Dunya is developing them in order to use them in the next world, which is Jannah.
But how do you develop them?
Through the Shariah.
Because Jannah is described as a world that is incredibly beautiful, a world that is governed by a Rab.
who is intensely merciful, who is constantly merciful.
The Sharia is the umbilical cord providing the sustenance for the development of our spiritual existence, of our spiritual being.
Now whether we believe in it or not, whether we want to or not, whether we execute it or not, that next world is inevitable.
It's coming.
Right?
Al Jannatahaqun, Wannarahaqun, Wal Mautahaqun, Wal Barasahaqun, Wal Mizanahaqun, Wa Saratahaqun.
Paradise is a reality.
Hellfire is a reality.
Death is a reality.
Rising from graves is a reality.
The scales in which our actions will be weighed, that is a reality.
The straight path is a reality.
Wa annasaata atiyatun laraibafiha.
And that appointed moment, it is coming.
There is absolutely no doubt about it.
That is the world in which justice will be exacted.
Every incident for which you said, where is justice?
On that day we will see justice.
The innocent people that suffered momentarily in this short span of life, this dunya, this world, their momentary suffering
will be balanced out with never-ending gifts and pleasures in the afterlife and the one who caused those sufferings for fleeting gains and pleasures their pleasures will be counterbalanced with grievous pain and everlasting torment but that day of judgment is coming
these are all descriptions of the day of judgment when this universe will be destroyed this this world that we are so comfortable in it's going to end that day is coming when souls will be paired together when you will finally meet those loved ones
who left you behind in this world and when that little girl who was buried alive will be asked for what sin were you killed this is the day where Allah will exact justice this is the day of justice not this world not this dunya that we're living in that day all the deeds will open up
And when the book of deeds will be made public, wa iza samaa ukushitaat And when the sky will be stripped away, wa izal jaheem usoa'irat And when that hellfire is set ablaze, wa izal jannatu uslifaat And when the paradise is brought near, alimat nafsun ma ahdarat Every soul will know what it has brought with it.
All good will be rewarded on that day and all bad will be punished on that day.
Allahu Akbar.
And the fact of the matter is that we have such a benevolent, such a merciful, such a loving master who is just dying to reward us for the smallest good deed that we do in this world.
You know, it has been narrated by the Prophet that
there will be a man on the day of judgment and all this man ever did was lend money to others.
He was a money lender.
And usually such people are black hearted people because of interest and they use that as a mechanism to gain worldly profit.
But when this man sent out his servants to collect the money that people owed him, if the person was having a hard time returning back that money,
If that's what the servant would return and tell him, he would say, forget about it.
So on the day of judgment, this man comes before Allah and he does not have any good deeds to his name, except that he used to do that.
And Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, He displays this man to everyone and He says, will I leave him to be more generous than me?
Will I leave this man to be more generous than me?
SubhanAllah.
He used to forgive people.
Do you think I am not going to forgive him today?
This is the master, the Rabb that we fail in our abudhiya towards.
On this day, every single good deed will be balanced with a reward from an immensely beneficent, from an incredibly loving and compassionate master.
All our delusions of grandeur in this world, they will be gone.
On that day, the muflis and the ghani, the destitute and the affluent, they will be separated.
Rasulullah once asked his companions
He asked, you know, man al-muflis.
Who is the muflis?
Who is the destitute?
They said, al-muflisu manla dinaru wala darhamu hindana ya Rasulullah.
The destitute is the one who does not have any darham or dinar to his name.
And the Prophet said, no.
He said, the greatest destitute of my Ummah on the Day of Judgment.
the greatest destitute of my Ummah on the Day of Judgment will be the one who comes with all of his prayers and all of his fasting and all of his Zakat wa ya'ti qat shata mahada wa qudifa haada wa akalamalaha haada wa safaqaddam mahada wa daraba haada but in addition to all of these good deeds he cheated this one
he lied to this one, he usurped the wealth of this one, he spilled the blood of this one, he struck this one.
And so his good deeds will be taken from his account and put into the account of this one and this one and this one.
And when his good deeds run out,
before justice is fully served the sins and falls of the remaining victims they will be taken from their accounts and added to his accounts and so despite living an entire life full of worship full of prayers full of fasting paying zakat because of his injustices that he committed with other people
because of the hurt that he caused to other people in this world.
This man will have to give up all his good deeds and he will have to take on all the horrible sins of his victims and he will finally be thrown into Hellfire.
This person, he said, will be the greatest destitute of my Ummah.
May Allah protect us all from being among these destitutes on the Day of Judgment.
Wahruddawan an alhamdulillahi rabbil alameen wassalatu wassalamu ala rasuli he saidina Muhammadin khatimin nabiin wassaidul Musaleen wala akhi wa wassi alibnabi talib aashrafil wassayeen walil aimatimin zoriatima taibinatahirin wassalam alayhi majmain al-fatah.